前面我们已经讲了
i hi的资源的一个封装的思路哈
那么作为一个C的
它本身它也是一个hi的资源哈
那么它的类就是这个FIHIC的
这跟之前的一模一样
他的思路也是hi里面去定义一个通用的类
然后会在D3d open gl
有的各个平台里面去实现它的子类继承
并且去实现它
所以在这个类里面呢就是只有一些简单的
比如说一些哈希一个名字
还有一个类型的美女值
就是这个fluency最下面的那个fluency
它其实就是定义了这个C的是哪个类型
到底是顶点C得啊
soc的啊
还是computer c的
还是什么光锥啊之类的
就是定义了一个类型的枚举值
那么它里面就是包含了它本大的类型啊
这个类就就是一个这样子就结束了
然后呢在它的子类里面
他先是继承了一层graphic的
然后在graphic的下面
就会有我们常见的那那些顶点着色器啊
max c的
还有这些像素折射器
那么它们的定义就非常简单
在这一个层面上就是非常简单
就是只是定义了这么一个类
甚至都没有什么新的变量跟函数
只是初始化它的类型
初始化那个刚才那个美女值它的类型
好嗯他们在D3D里面去
比如说我们看一下它的子类
我们就拿一个顶点着色器来看一下
其他的都是类似的
比如说顶点着色器
那么它在D3D里面应该就是
呃我看下
搜一下吧
应该是FD三D十二五TXC的啊
这是啥对
那么第3D12里面就是会继承这个C的
然后继承他就想挨着挨着去实现
但是呢它更多的实现了
它放在了另外一个那个父类里面去实现
就是这个第三第12C的data里面
就是那些数据是存储在这里
那是一个C的着色器
最重要的就是它的代码咯
就是这个就是代码
然后在D3D12
D3D12里面的代码就处理的就比较简单
它就直接可以把它啊
转换成D3D12的那个say BO
就是直接用它来转换这个
然后再加一些什么feature level啊
呃没有了
那么实现起来也是比较简单
主要是存储了编译
存储了这个C的
还有一些相关的东西
呃那怎么创建一个C的呢
怎么创建一个C的呢
那就是他的就是有一个hi create
Seed
拼错了吗
V24是
对就是他那么根据代码去
克里A1个C的呢
就是这里面的定义的一个这样子的一个函数哈
它也是定义在dynamic h r h r里面的哈
就是这里面也是定义在这个dnm hi里面的
定义在这个这个打联m hr里面的
那么实现呢就是会真正在平台的子类去实现哈
那比如说open gl了
那他同样道理
在open g20里面的达尼美HI就会继承它
并且实现这个函数哈
然后我们跳进去看一下
呃他大概呢就是会先处理一下代码
因为什么呢
因为U1里面这个传进来的代码呢
它是并不只是代码本身
它还附带了额外的参数
那么所以他在这个类里面呢
他用了一个leader
谁谁的COLEADER这样的类去帮忙解析它的数据
我们跳进去看一下这个类
好他把传进来
我们直接看到最下面的这个函数
那首先呢它你看函数名字就知道了
有一个optional data
也就是说它它其实在这个内存里面
他在拼
在后面会会拼一段option的data
就是说他在传进来的一段内存里面
前半部分是真正的代码本身
后半部分是一些optional的数据
他最后整一个内存
最后的那个那个位置就是大
记录着这些数据的大小
那那他这个获取到第零个
就是一开始的指针地址
然后加上它的长度
那不就是最后最末尾的那个位置吗
然后最末尾的那个位置强行转换成一个呃
按S32的
然后就把它解析出来
那么这个就带最后最末尾的那个位置
就呃它的数字就是代表了在这段内存里面
那个表示optional data的那个长度
就是到底哪些内存是表示数据
哪些内存是表示代码
那么前半部分就是代码
那那比如说直接用总长减去数据的长度
那就是代码的长度
那就是代码的强度好
那我们也知道
那他怎么他也要提供了
解析这个具体的数据的那个方法
比如说我们随便看一个
比如说这个呃它的后半部分存储起来的数据呢
它就是会有key
会有一个key
就是一个id
根据id定义不同的的数据
那我们看一下它的流程
那他首先拿到最末尾的这个地址
最末尾这个地址
然后又拿到data的长度
然后用最末尾的再减去这个长度
那就是data的开始的位置
就是追第一个data的位置
那么第一个
然后呢
他就通过一个外循环去把它解解析出来这个key
然后判断这个key跟你函数传进来的key
是不是相等
如果相等
我就返回到对应的这个数据
如果不是
那就是下一个下一个
然后继续去判断
那他就提供了这样的方法
在嗯数据的那一段内存里面
根据这个key去找到对应的data
当然塔还封装了同时获取的data
跟那个那个data的size
以及它还实现了一个模板类
直接帮你转成任意的模板
直接把你转成任意的模板
这个呢就是他在这段代码里面哈
它附加了一些额外的数据
就是这个SETCOVID的类的实现好
那么回过头来再G在GL里面去创建一个C得
那他当然要把这些数据解析出来对吧
然后最重要的其实就是把那段代码编译
把那段代码编译
其实就是在比较下面啊
嗯找一下呃
这个这个就是他会做一个转换哈
GLSL的转换哈
因为open gl的各种平台呃
是代码上是需要做一些变化的哈
那这个不属于我们今天的内容哈
那他处理好之后
就会把真正的那个代码的内存传进来
然后去编译
编译呢
其实就是很很就是直接调GL本身的那个了
那他先找到先搞一个resource出来
那在GL里面的resource就是一个5号整数哈
那么它就会在这里面去编译哈
编译就是直接调open gl里面的那个API的函数哈
那就是这些seed resource
comprised seder啊
就是把它编译出来
然后下面就是去处理一下
它编译是不是有报错啊
如果有报错就做对应的处理啊
诸如此类
那么这个就是在open gl里面的那个点create一个SHADER
create一个seed
就是把代码传进来
然后去创建一个i hi的SEDER的对象实例
那么同样道理我们去看一下哦
哦哦D3D12里面的实现
D3D12里面的实现就简单的多了
因为它没有那个中间的翻译的过程哈
它不在D3D12里面
它不像open gl啊
各个platform就是各个平台或者不一样呃
它的代码要做调整哈
那它其实本身就直接创建好
就直接创建
那这个就是D3D12的i hi哈
D3D12的单页面hi
那么它调用的函数
当然了
他也有也有这个解析这个code的那个optional data的
那个就是传进来的
还是也是附带的各种参数的哈
那么他把那个数据解析出来了
然后就直接初始化一下哈
然后这里就是把那些呃optional data读取出来哈
赋值到对应的地方而已哈
然后就直接赋值给他
直接把代码
直接把代码的地址布置给他就结束了
因为因为因为我们刚才说什么
在D3D12里面的这个顶点着色器
它在这里面它其实是什么
它的代码是什么
它的代码就是直接把这个地址转换成D3
D12的BO哈
就是他啊所以在在那个位置上他直接复制过来
然后到时候要用的时候就直接转换就可以了
那这个就是D3D12的C得的实现
就是顶点着色器
那么在这个层面上
就是最最最底层的hi层面的C的
他大概就是讲这样
他起码就提供了一些把代码
根据代码把代码传进来
然后去create这个对象
创建这个C的
当然了
还有一些实现一些其他的方法
比如说设置它的一些参数或者什么东西
那这个是底层上面的
那么在最上层
我们更加熟悉的
就是我们平时真正的去实现一些效果
其实是那个FC的
就是这个类
那现在我们这个类这个类似C德的上层呃
我们看一下看一眼
我撤销这个修改
OK那这个很多同学可能就会比较熟悉啊
就是我们比如说我们自己写了一个C的HL
根据HLSL去写了一个C的
那我们要怎么去在U1里面用起来呢
我们一般来说就会写一个自己的类
去继承这个global seed啊
当然也不一定
那大多数都是继承global seder
global seed本身呢就是继承FC的一个类
哎
所以呢MC的呢就是所有在上层逻辑上里面的
那个C的就积累呃
不是这个这个是上层逻辑的啊
i hi的都是有i hi开头的
IHI是底层的哈
在这个类
然后我们先看一下
先不着急
我们先看一下我们平时是怎么用的
我们会去啊继承这个类
然后呢用用两个宏是吧啊
按照约定的方式
就是一定要加上这些两个红
然后呢我们还要告诉最重要的要告诉什么
告诉C的参数格式
就是我们上一节课讲的
就是要告诉你对应这些代码用到的参数
那么就是我们还要去按照这个格式
一个begin
一个beginside panama
然后一个N在中间用这个宏去组装一个
我们这个C的对应的参数格式
参数格式按照这个格式
那么它到底是怎么起作用的呢
怎么起作用的呢
那么呃就分为就是说它的参数是怎么收集的好
那我们带着这个疑问去看一下这些红的代码哈
看下这是我的代码
首先呢我们看一下最基本的FC的这个类哈
FC的这类呃
他当然他定义了这些什么呃
编译环境发生改变啊
或者之类的
要不要要不要编译这个PERMITATION
这个是排列组合哈
呃这里提一下这个排列组合是什么意思呢
就是说他同一份代码呃
在U1里面
同一份代码它还有可能会有不同的编译选项
就是在HLSL里面的代码里面
我们会经常看到那种有一个呃有不同的分支的
那么我看看有没有哈
我看看
啊这个对这个
类似这些哈
类似这些我们在平时我们写的这个USF啊
就是这个U1里面按照U1的格式去写
我看到的代码了之后
会经常会碰到这些
就是有点像CC加加的代码
就是如果有有这个就走这个分支
如果没有就不走这个分支是吧
那么这个东西是怎么实现呢
这个东西本身就是U1去实现了一套呃
编译的系统哈
就是因为因为我们写的这些真正的写的这些
USF的这着色器的代码
它还不是最终的编译的代码
它经过转换的
比如说呃
比如说呃这个是官方的一个一个
那个就是说这个HLSL它的代码
它会经过自己优于改装过实现过的一个转换
mc pp跟这个H2S的cc转换
最后才慢慢的转换成
比如说在open gl里面
就是转换成GSL的这样一个代码啊
那么在整个转换过程中呢
它就会他就会去检测像这些自己的一些选项
接下来呃要不要编译这段代码
那么像一个UUSF里面
是不是有很多这种选项啊
那不同的选项就构成了不同的排列组合哈
那么就是就是这个permutation啊
这个permutation就是说它会根据你有哪些选项
然后自动的去计算呃
不同的排列组合
就比如说你比如说你有三个选项啊
那就是虽然是同一份代码
但是它的编译选项是不一样的
那他也要编译一次不一样的SHADER哈
那这里是提到了一个这个东西
但是这个代码的转换啊是非常复杂的
呃我们就暂时去不去涉及那一块的领域啊
但是知道有这么一件事
就是如果你看到这个permutation
相关相关的这种类
你就知道C的它就算是同一份代码
它也会有不同的选项去编译成不同的的
真正的那个那个谁的
但是如果是相同的选项
他就不便宜了
他就直接拿出来了
它会存储起来
所以呢他会有这个过程哈
嗯还有一些key啊
get type这些常见的函数啊
get fluence就是拿出它的类型啊
这些这些函数哈
那么我们今天还要重点关注的
另外一个一个代码呢
就是说这个FC的呢
它是它不像一个actor里面
它没有自自带的那个那一套反射机制
那我们去采集他的信息的时候
我们它是U1是通过一套单独的实现
额外的实现
就是这个type layout去实现这个反射的机制
就是比如说它在下面定义的这些变量
比如说它定义的这些变量
它就不像呃我们u object
它因为它不是继承u object的
它不是像我那种就是用一个u property啊
就可以拿到它的反射了
那么它在这个层面上
比如说它需要这些的这些成员变量
它其实这里呢就是定义一个啊
这样这个哈希的类型啊
这样子名字的成员变量
但是呢它需要实现一套新的反射机制
那么他就是用这个宏来实现的这个红白实线了
这个我们可以把它打开
看一下它的原理
其实原理很简单
我们把它展开
呃我们加一下换行符好看一点
他大概就是提供了一个get type layout的方法
get type layout的方法
这是一个函数
然后他也他这里他是怎么收集
他就是怎么收集成员变量的信息
就说为什么为什么我们下面的这些变量
我们下面的这些变量加了这个东西
它就有反射的信息
那么反射的信息是什么
反射的信息
就是说呃
我知道这个成员变量的名字就是字符串
我把一个叫做bidding的字符串
跟这个成员变量真正的指针对应起来
还有一些其他的信息
然后存储起来
那么自然而然
我在别的地方
我只只用这个像脚本一样
用这个八点的这个字符串
我就能get到八点的这个真正的这个变量的指针
然后获取到它真正的值
那就是反射信息
所以我们要收集这个信息
那么它这里呢就会自动的去去搜集哈
它其实这里啊这里又有个很关键的东西
它定义了一个模板结构体
Internal link time
它定义了一个这样子的结构体
而且这个结构体的模板参数呢是一个整数
是一个整数
那它有什么特殊的地方呢
它是这样子的
它会在每一个layout里面都会有这个定义
我们也把这个layout展开
OK这是一个啊
我们加下面这个
我们也把它展开
诶怎么还不出来
啊先不管
好那我们看layer field层面展开的是什么东西
呃
这个
看到没有
他实现了第一
他当然他当然是先定义一个这样子的成员变量
然后呢搞一堆这种这种对齐
啊啊就是这个tempo templing
我们也把它放下来
他首先是定义了这个成员变量本身
然后呢它定义一个新的模板类
就是也是internal limti
但是他从他自己定义的参数呢就是固定值
固定值这里的不太准确的
这展开的不太准确
但是就是说他这个固定值
然后他实现了里面的这个给你手来的方法
然后你看它的真正的实现方法
有什么意特别之处
它在这个INITIL的函数的第一步
是先调用加一的给你手来的方式
那聪明的读者应该就马上联想得到
他肯定是在某个地方调一个初始的值
没错
它就是会掉一个internal link time
一传进来的模板参数就是一
那么它调传进来的模板参数一的方法
但是模板参数一如果有
那么他就会第一步就会先调模板参数二
模板参数二就会掉模板参数三
模板参数三就会掉
模板参数是一直直到那个最大的数字
发现它没有定义
没有定义怎么办
没有定义
那就是调用默认的定义
默认的定义就是什么都没做
默认的定义
这个是默认的模板参数函数
默认的就是什么都不做
如果有定义
那么它就会链式形成一个链式的结构
调模板一的函数
510的函数内部本身先去掉二的函数
二的先去掉三的
就是这个这句话就是就他最巧妙的地方
然后他调完他链式的去掉那些函数
最终它本身它在下面就接着来
就把自己真的信息加进去
那比如说这个biding
这个biding他首先构造了这个对吧
他构造了它的名字
一个字符串的名字
然后这个这个是什么
这个单独的这行
这个就是把这个biding的地址
首先它强行转换成这个父类的
这个这个类型的指针
然后拿出他成员变量的位置
然后把这个成员变量的位置强行转换
乘一个加这个char
那么它其实是拿到什么
是拿到了这个成员变量
相对于这类这个FC的这个类的内存的
一个指针上的位移
就是拿到一个位移
也就是一个offset
也就是说我如果拿到这个FC的指针
我加上这个offset之后
我就拿到了真正的八点的地址
然后我强行的把那个地址
那个指针强行的转换成这个
我就能拿到这段内存的数据了
所以其实就就是相当于是
我现在就在收集他的名字
它的成员变量的指针
然后把还有一些其他信息全部把它收集起来
全部把它收集起来
然后
就把所有的这种layout field的信息收集起来了
因为它是个链式结构
那那你看下面一个下面一个能不能打开哦
可以下面有个变量它也一样
那它不是一个map map info吗
你看是不是一个parameter map info
我要定义它
它其实一开始就先先先定义那个
我又展开不了了
就他他本身也会先先去定义这个东西
然后它本身的这个initialize
那他本身也有这个initialize
也会掉加一
一直往下加
每一个这个layer都会加一
它怎么实现这个加一呢
它其实是我们跳到这个红的这个最后面啊
其实你会看到这个东西啊
这个这个两个下划线
一个counter哈
这个是编译器对它的一个预定义
宏的一个实现哈
就是你每写一次它它就会加一
每节一次它它就会加一
所以你一直用它就会不断的去加一
它就自动的实现了这个加一的功能
那当然了
这里展开的这个看到的这个数字是不太准确的
是不太准确的呃
这个393是不太准确的
先不理对
不用管
反正他就是会加一
然后就所有的信息就通过这个一开始定义的
这个initialize
然后就通过这个递归的模板链接
就把所有变量的信息收集起来了啊
我们把这些撤销
所以呢在FC的里面他没有不像
它不是继承u up主
他没有反射机制
它就定义了这个type layout啊
然后所以你需要有反射的变量
它就用layout vie来定义啊
那就是一个啊
这个还不是我们这个只是提供了反射的机制哈
提供了反射的机制
那在下面呢它还有一个就是参数
C的本身的参数还是怎么收集的呢
有点类似
我们找一个案例来看就可以了
我们就是看它吧
这个default light vs
看它嗯
这个这个就是定义一个结构体
定一个参数的结构体
然后通过这个宏
也是把这个参数的结构体收集起来
那我们可以把它展开
他们的定义哈也是类似一个模板的参数
模板的那个递归的那种
好可以了
给我们讲了两个参数
电脑有点慢啊
OKOK展开
这个也转换一下
那他首先他begin里面呢
他begin里面的定义的这个这个
等一下稍等一下好
就是这个函数
你剩下的慢慢看就可以了
其他的没有什么特点哈
就是定义了一个jj a per
game p r v这样子的一个函数
它返回的是一个指针
就是返回下一个指针
它本身呢它是一个
那这个呢本身是一个函数
定义了一个函数
就是说他传一个参数进来
然后从两个参数进来
然后最后会返回一个外星的指针
这外形指针就是下一个函数指针
然后嗯我们看一下它还有一个对应的
就是我们写那个着色器的时候
我们还要写一个这个通过这个improvement global season
来
把我们写的这个类
跟真正的着色器的那个代码文件
以及它的入口函数
以及它的类型来注册到新引擎里面去
那他是注册到引擎里面去
其实是就是把这个信息放在某个地方
那他大概就是展开它
其实就是实现了一个static layout的方法
这个这个函数我们把它放好
其实它就是实现了
在这个类里面实现了一个static glayout的方法
就是别人直接调你的这个static gay or的静态
静态方法
就能获取到这个tab layout
这个tape vil
就是获取到它它所有那个收集到的信息
那他是怎么去收集的呢
他就是会掉这个函数
我们把这个加在换行啊
太强了
那这个这里电定应该是掉了
那个加一些换行
加些换行
太多了
哦到了到了到了到了
那他的steady layout其实在最下面三行啊
我们只关注这几行
看到没有
刚才我们说那个模板类那个internal time
他一定默认你调用这个implementation这个宏
它默认的这帮你生成这个函数
这个函数默认就是会掉这个一
这个模板参数是一的initialize
然后刚才我们已经知道了
调一的initialize
一的就会先掉二的
二的就会到掉三的
三的就会掉四的
一直直到没有没有为止
它就会进入到默认的那个呃
就啥也不做的那个函数
然后就结束了
这是他嗯
那这里呢这里呢是收集那个着色器的参数
射击着色器的参数呢
它其实是定义了这个这样一个play get play的函数啊
但是它参数不一样的
你会发现每个变量的参数都不一样
比如说这里定义的是传入了一个什么
first member id的的那个
这里定义的是传入了一个next meer id view
而下面这个是传入了这个
你看这个变量这个类型
这个类型是不一样的
对不对
所以它其实是是不同的
名字是一样的
函数的名字是一样的呃
但是它的它是它是不同的
它参数的类型是不一样的
那么它怎么实现一实现一个链式结构呢
它其实就是在最下面
最下面会先掉这个呃
他OK
那这里有个外循环
这里有一个外循环
最下面的这个那个宏是N哈
那一开始是一个begin
然后中间三个变量
三个变量
然后最下一段是一个N结束
在结束在N的宏里面定义呢
它是有一个度外循环的
这个do while循环
它就是先拿出第一个
先拿出第一个
它是倒叙过来的
这个第一个就是最后的一个参数的定义的
那个函数
然后他先执行
他执行这个函数
它执行这个函数
这个函数就会收集对应的信息添加进去
然后它还会返回一个指针
那个返回的指针是什么呢
那么比如说它执行了这个函数
执行了这个函数
它实际上返回的指针就是上一个
那我们看一下就知道了
嗯这里我们先加一下
换行好看一点
啊到他了到他了
给他一开始先调第一个
第一个就是它
那么就是这个函数
这个函数他会收集这一堆信息
收集这一堆这个变量的信息
包括比如说这个这个是我们常见的
就是拿到这个变量的偏移
变量的偏移就是用用一个零潜行的转
换成是假设是他一个指针
然后拿出这个成员变量的位置
然后强行转换做一个场景转化
那么它就是拿到这个变量的这个在对象里面
这个指针的那个偏移哈
就是成员变量的指针的偏移
那么它包括这些全全部的各种各样的信息哈
这些信息收集起来
它会添加到这个member里面
A进去
那就是相当于是把这个变量的信息存储起来了
把这个变量的信息存储起来之后
它就会在最后返回返回它返回的这一个指针
这个指针其实就是你看他投入的参数是什么
是9match的
是这个9match
9match函数是哪个结合编曲是什么东西
你看它它上下是连在一起的哈
它它就是中间的那个上一个红
它定义没完
他下一个
接下来的话
那这个gee match其实就是通过type define
就是这个full scream
那这个full scream那就是它
所以它形成也形成了一个链式结构
就是你调这个最末尾的这个函数
调完这个函数
它会返回上一个变量的函数
那就是返回它的这个函数
这个函数会收先收集这个变量对应的信息
收集完这个变量的信息
它又会返回上一个变量的指针
那么变量的函数的指针那就是返回它
他执行完就会返回上一
再返回上一个
那因为他是第一个
他返回的上一个就是没有了
那就是执行到这个最begin默认的这个这个指针
那它返回的是空指针
那么在最后的这个空返回空指针
那这个度外循环就结束了
那这个呢就是C的里面的去收集信息的哈
所以通过这样一个红
通过这样一个红
他就把这个PANAMETER
这个参数的结构的信息收集起来了
就是这个时候我把信息收集起来
就相当于是我就知道你现在有三个变量
一个view
一个full screen
这个IST
一个是9match
你有三个变量
你这三个变量
偏移啊
指针啊
还有一些明智的信息啊
各种信息全部都收集起来了
那自然而然
到时候我就可以拿这份信息去匹配
你这个这个着色器了对吧
这个格式格式我知道了
就是收收集起来了
然后还要用一个use哈
Use
因为这里实际上是定义了一个新的结构体哈
这个实际上是定义了一个新的结构体哈
它实际上是定义了一个一个define哈
一个我看看
应该是定义了一个洞
嗯struck啊
对type info
类似它定义了一个结构体
然后这个use你先不聊
这个use的其实就是get哈
比如说这个parameter的type info
Palameter
The type info
是不是
就是他是不是
就是在这里面定义的一个新的结构体
type info的结构体
然后第二这个结构体的这个GDP data
获取它的原数据哈
就是在这个结构体里面定义的这个函数的哈
呃就是把它换行看一下
那你看这些名字都信息都是全部收集起来了哈
啊对对对
这个函数就是它在在这个参数里面的宏
是定义了一个这样子的结构体
这样子的结构体里面是有一个这样的函数
然后需要你去用一个use在前面
在整个你自定义的这个着色器的类里面
用了那个U之后
他其实就把它串联起来了哈
到时候它就自动的拿到这些信息了
这个呢就是呃怎么收集信息的一个代码
那看起来他有点复杂
但是其实它的核心原理
只要你知道他的目标是什么
然后他其实
然后再加上他其实实现了一个链式结构
那么代码就不会变得复杂了哈
那这个呢就是呃C的层面他怎么去收集参数
实现反射的一个机制
呃
今天我们只是简单的了解一下西德的一部分哈
还有更多的其他的东西呢
我们在后面还要慢慢的去去看啊
还有很多方面的领域哈
今天这个呢就是先讲一下它最基础的
最基础的就是i hi前面的那个C的
它是怎么创建的
然后我们上层逻辑的这个C的
它是怎么实现了一套反射的机制机制
然后它的参数是怎么收集起来的
有了这些信息
我们就能真正的去编译C的
拿到呃准备好
当然了
还有一部分我们后面再讲
还有部分就是说有了这些SHADER了之后
怎么去用它
调用它
然后或者是给这些C的床真正的参数值啊
然后形成一个呃渲染的一个pass
那个是后面的
我们今天先啊看这个基础的部分
因为我们先把各种基础的先了解一遍以后
后面我们才会得心应手
不然的话就是说后面看别的代码了
就是会哎又碰到一个新的类
又又大概不知道他长什么样子哈
所以我们不要着急
好我们今天就先这么多